It may not be the only reason why the original
Star Wars trilogy was a hit with adults and
kids, but the straightforward story didn’t
hurt.
No need to get bogged down in politics or
star systems, just know to root for the young
rebels taking down the evil, planet-exploding
Empire.
As an added bonus, the movie’s hero managed
to turn his father back to the light, taking
down the villain together.
Or did they?
It’s a question that the new trilogy will
probably answer, if The Force Awakens is anything
to go by and YES, there will be SPOILERS.
But to understand the real meaning of Star
Wars, the studying the full saga is key – and
if you catch the hidden story at its core,
you might even guess what’s coming in the
next chapter of the Star Wars universe.
Keep in mind this is our theory and you will
see that the proof we bring forward might
make you see Star Wars in a whole different
way…
That’s the plan for our latest Docu Series,
The Hidden Truth Behind Star Wars.
Starting At The Middle
By now most Star Wars fans know that the first
movie was actually the fourth chapter of George
Lucas’ original story, and it’s not hard
to see why he thought it was the one most
likely to win over movie audiences.
Take away the spaceships and lightsabers,
and Luke is your average fantasy hero, born
from nothing, recruited by a wise old wizard,
and trained to be the great hero he was destined
to be.
George Lucas admitted from the start that
he was just copying classic stories and archetypes
for Luke’s heroic journey, and as he became
a more experienced Jedi Knight, even his father
Darth Vader couldn’t help but see the light.
The trilogy ended with Luke saving the day,
and wiping out the Dark Side once and for
all… at least, that’s what we thought.
Until Lucas decided to tell the REAL start
of the story, re-defining Luke’s journey
in more ways than fans may even realize.
The Real Story of Anakin Skywalker
While the last half of the Star Wars story
saw Darth Vader travel from Dark to Light,
the first half of the story was the exact
opposite, showing his fall from light to dark,
making him as central to the story as his
son.
In fact, Luke’s story became a perfect echo
of his father’s.
Beginning his life as Anakin Skywalker, he
too lived on an isolated desert planet, forgotten
by the galaxy until The Force intervened,
guiding another old Jedi to him.
A Jedi who would see him as important, and
recruit him to fight a growing darkness, decades
before the exact same thing would happen to
his son.
But Luke was only important because he was
Anakin’s son – Anakin was important for
a completely different reason.
If you believe the Jedi in the films, Anakin
was born from The Force itself, to become
the Chosen One, a prophesied person who would
finally bring balance to the Force.
To the Jedi, that meant defeating their enemies,
the Sith, once and for all – and use of
the Dark Side along with them.
When you combine both trilogies, Skywalker
and his son fulfilled the prophecy together,
but it wasn’t easy.
The two heroes didn’t just face the same
journey, but the same choice: with the future
of the galaxy on their shoulders, would they
choose the Dark Side to protect their family,
or the Light, for the good of the galaxy?
It’s important to point out that it isn’t
ever stated as Good over Evil, just Dark and
Light sides.
After all, the Jedi tell Anakin that love
leads to the Dark Side – and it’s a need
to protect his wife that does him in.
Since George Lucas took inspiration from humanity’s
earliest stories for the Star Wars saga, his
description of The Force sounds more like
Yin and Yang than good over evil.
Yin and Yang… and The Force
George Lucas never denied his eastern influences
when he created the Star Wars Universe.
Everyone knows the Yin and Yang symbol for
this element of Chinese mythology, but the
actual meaning of Yin and Yang may be hard
to separate from The Force at all.
When all creation was chaos, there were two
opposite forces.
Rather than fighting, the two reached a balance,
and out of them was born the first human.
Sound familiar?
But one wasn’t evil or good, just opposite.
Where one may be dark or old, the other is
white and youthful.
Different teachings may favor one side over
the other, but only a balance between the
two can bring peace.
The Jedi are looking for the same thing, but
miss one key point: both sides are equally
important, and constantly struggling back
and forth.
There’s another major clue that The Force
follows the same rule, and you can find it
by looking at the Yin and Yang symbol.
Notice that the black and white aren’t just
balanced, but have a piece of the other at
their core.
It’s the same with the forces of good and
evil in Star Wars.
The Jedi and Republic claim to be good, but
fear, paranoia, and control take root in the
prequels – and literally, the Emperor in
disguise.
In the original trilogy, Darth Vader sits
in the heart of the Dark Side, but only his
son can see that he’s still good at heart.
These similarities show what most people miss
about the Star Wars story: it’s not a tale
of good winning over evil; just The Force
swinging back and forth.
It’s family that sends Anakin to the Dark
Side, but it’s family that pulls him back.
The Force created Anakin with a choice to
shift things off balance, and his son was
lost, then found, to shift it back.
So even though Luke thought the fight was
over at the end of Episode 6, The Force had
other ideas.
The Force Awakens
Since shifting The Force out of balance is
a Skywalker trademark, then Episode 7 shouldn’t
have been a surprise.
Where Luke relied on Anakin to fight back
the Dark, Ben Solo, Leia’s son, relied on
Anakin to help the Dark Side grow.
Again, another hero on a desert planet is
pulled into a galactic mission, and even gets
her own wise old man to guide her path.
The mentor meets the same end of Qui-Gon Jinn
and Ben Kenobi before, leaving the hero to
rely on family to restore balance to The Force
– with a new mentor, as well.
The Force’s True Purpose
After thousands of years of conflict between
the Sith and Jedi, the Emperor rose to shift
power back to the middle, The Force created
Anakin to make it possible, and Luke arrived
to once again set things right.
Family helped Luke achieve victory, but family
delivered the cruelest twist years later,
when his nephew and apprentice turned against
him.
Whether Rey is or isn’t related to the Skywalker
clan, she’s walking the path that Anakin
and Luke did before her.
If the ways of The Force keep up, Rey should
forget about defeating the Dark Side once
and for all, and stick to the task at hand.
After all, the next age of peace, or age of
conflict will be on its way not long after.
And odds are, a Skywalker will be at the center
of it – not on the side of good or evil,
just Light, or Dark… exactly as The Force
wills it.
This theory makes total sense when you look
at the full Star Wars saga.
The Force, just like the Yin and the Yang,
is basically a perfect balance of Good and
Evil, Shadow and Light, The Dark Side and
the Light Side…
One side needs the other side to exist.
It’s somewhat expected that the new Trilogy
will follow the same path as the two before
it.
J.J. Abrams has taken some heat when people
accused him of almost entirely copying the
two first trilogies when making The Force
Awakens but when we analyze the hidden truth,
it was clear what creative choice he needed
to make…
That’s our perspective on the Force, and
it’s one that’s harder to come by when
the Star Wars story is only told by one side
of the struggle.
But what do you think?
Have we missed any key points or parallels?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.